à voisins le bretonneux l'espace jeunes
de la maison du lac ouvre ses portes
pendant la période estivale et propose
des dizaines d'animations pour innover
chaque année la structure imaginent de
nouvelles activités
exemple avec cet atelier de création de
tee-shirts c'est une nouveauté qui a été
ta part notre animateur jean evans
donc c'est un peu dans l'air du temps
souvent les jeunes les aime bien vont
porter des vêtements de marque là on
leur a proposé de créer leur propre
marque
donc ils ont d'abord fait un travail de
recherche avec l'animateur autour de du
logo qui voulait créer et ensuite ils
l'ont ils ont fait le design et ils vont
leur passé et le mettre sur un tee shirt
qu'ils ont pris qu'ils ont ramené avec
cet après-midi-là quatre jeunes
collégiens se sont improvisés styliste
et ont participé à la fabrication de cet
objet unique
l'activité a du succès j'aime bien
fabriquer des choses dans mes mains du
coup j'ai fait j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant et je ça pourrait me plaire
du coup bah je les fais ici pour
m'amuser tour et des choses comme de la
pâtisserie des bracelets de la peinture
cet après midi on aurait une marque de
tee shirt sa propre marque
j'ai fait
il a marqué
mende d'autres activités sont proposées
pendant les deux mois d'ouverture cet
été comme des sorties en plein air des
tournois sportifs ou de jeux vidéo
une recette qui fonctionne la demande
est en hausse depuis quelques années je
peux revenir déjà sur la décision que
nous avons prise en 2017 d'oeuvre ir ce
service jeunesse sur les deux mois d'été
ce qui auparavant il ne fonctionner que
sur le mois de juillet était fermée
trois semaines au mois d'août et ouvrez
simplement à la fin du mois sur la
dernière semaine pour une révision un
peu scolaire avant la rentrée des
classes
les activités se termineront le 28 août
juste avant la rentrée des classes